When thinking about a product or service
that is sold by an organization, we
don't often think about the individual
components that make up that final
product. But in reality, it is that
supply chain that creates an additional
security concern for everything that we
do as a company. The supply chain that
creates the final product could include
raw materials and suppliers of those raw
materials. It might include
manufacturers and distributors that get
those products to you. And it also
involves your customers and consumers of
your product. Every point of this supply
chain becomes a security concern and
attackers would like to get their way
into the supply chain so that they can
eventually make their way into your
network. This means that an exploit with
a raw material supplier that is used to
create a product that you purchase could
potentially be a security problem within
your organization. You have no control
over the security associated with those
raw material suppliers. You're not
involved with the process, but
ultimately this now becomes a security
concern for you. So although we have
complete control over the IT security of
our own organization, we may not have
that same visibility for any of our
providers. In many cases, these
thirdparty providers might already have
access to our network because we might
have an internal portal that they use to
determine what tasks we would like them
to perform. This is a perfect
opportunity for someone who wants to
attack your network. If they can gain
access to the provider network, they can
then gain access to your network. And if
you think about all of the different
providers used by your organization,
this becomes a very big list. This could
be a network provider, a utility,
someone who does office cleaning, maybe
it's a payroll company that you work
with. If any of these third party
providers are compromised, the attacker
could use that access to begin attacking
your network. This is why many
organizations are writing into their
service contract that they need access
to audit the security of their
providers. This allows an organization
to understand what type of security
their providers are using and if there
is an opportunity to provide additional
security, it would show up during one of
these audits.
A good example of how security at a
provider could affect your organization
occurred in November 2013 with the
Target Corporation. This allowed for 40
million credit cards to be stolen all
because of air conditioning. This
started with a heating, ventilation, and
air conditioning firm in Pennsylvania
that was infected through an email
message that contained malware. That
malware allowed attackers access to the
systems within this HVAC company. And
they ultimately were able to gain VPN
credentials from that HVAC company that
was used to access the target network.
This HBAC company used this VPN to gain
access to vendor resources on the target
network. Unfortunately, at the time, the
target network was one large network
that did not separate the vendor network
from the point of sale network. This
meant that once the attacker accessed
the target network, they effectively had
access to every store in the Target
system. They then infected point of sale
terminals inside of Target to start
collecting credit card numbers and they
collected millions of these numbers
before they were discovered. This was a
significant breach for Target and it was
created because of the vendor
relationship they had with this HVAC
company.
In your company, you probably have
switches, routers, firewalls, and many
other devices that you're putting into
your network. But when you install one
of these new switches or routers, are
you sure there's nothing malicious
inside of those components? In order to
address concerns with the supply chain,
many organizations are limiting who they
work with to acquire these types of
hardware. If you can trust your vendor,
then you can often trust the equipment
that you're installing into your
network. Many organizations are also
performing additional checks of the
equipment they receive to ensure that it
is legitimate and from the original
manufacturer. This is now part of the
normal security policies for many
organizations and they are performing
extensive checks of everything they're
bringing in the door.
Switches and routers would make an
excellent attack point. They're devices
that are plugged into the network. They
all have an IP address and they're
watching every bit of data go through
our internal network. But how do you
know if the switches and routers that
you're receiving are real or if they're
counterfeit? This was the problem that
was discovered in July of 2022 when the
Department of Homeland Security arrested
a reseller CEO that had been selling
non-legitimate Cisco products. This
individual sold more than $1 billion of
counterfeit switches and counterfeit
routers with the Cisco label. They had
created over 30 different companies in
order to sell all of this different
equipment and had been selling them
since 2013. And although we don't
believe there was any security concern
with the software that was running on
these devices, it definitely was not
legitimate software. There was certainly
the potential for security concern,
especially considering how much
equipment was sold and how long that
equipment had been selling. Ultimately,
these were found to be very poorly
performing pieces of equipment. They
said Cisco on the front, but they were
not Cisco inside of the device. And once
these devices started breaking and some
of them actually catching on fire, did
everybody put together that perhaps they
weren't receiving legitimate Cisco
equipment?
Not only do we install a lot of
switches, routers, and other hardware,
we also install a lot of software. And
each time that we install software onto
our computers, we have to trust that the
code that we're installing is
legitimate. Fortunately, much of the
software that we install today includes
a digital signature. So you know that
the code that you're installing is
exactly the same code that was sent by
the software developer. This also
becomes a concern when we think about
updates or upgrades. Often these updates
are downloaded and installed
automatically. But how safe are the
update files that we're receiving? We've
not only seen this with commercial
software, we've also seen malware
integrated into open-source software. So
even though the source code is
accessible and anyone can read through
it, attackers can sometimes get their
malicious software put into the code
itself and ultimately compiled into the
software that you use.
A significant supply chain attack
occurred with software created by Solar
Winds, specifically a product named
Orion that was used by over 18,000
customers around the world, including
many very large companies and the US
government. This attack occurred inside
the Solar Winds network itself and the
attacker was able to get their malicious
code put into the software before it was
digitally signed and sent to customers.
The malicious code was added in March
and June of 2020, but it wasn't
discovered until December of 2020 and by
then it had been distributed to many
customers. This malicious code was
installed on these Orion systems which
then allowed the attackers access to the
customers networks. Not only was Solar
Winds Orion running in companies such as
Microsoft, Cisco, and Intel, it was also
in federal government facilities such as
the Pentagon, Homeland Security, the
State Department, the Department of
Energy, and others. This was one of the
most significant supply chain attacks
that we've ever experienced and it's one
that has changed the way that we look at
how we receive and update software on
our networks.